By this point, we have
discussed pretty much
everything that is to be said
about individual discrete
random variables.
Now let us move to the case
where we're dealing with
multiple discrete random
variables simultaneously, and
talk about their distribution.
As we will see, their
distribution is characterized
by a so-called joint PMF.
So suppose that we have a
probabilistic model, and on
that model we have defined
two random variables--
X and Y. And that we
have available
their individual PMFs.
These PMFs tell us about one
random variable at the time.
This tells us about X, this
tells us about Y. But they do
not give us any information
about how the two random
variables are related
to each other.
For example, if you wish to
answer this question, whether
the numerical values that the
two random variables happen to
be equal, and what is the
probability of that event, you
will not be able to answer this
question if you only know
the two individual PMFs.
In order to be able to answer
a question of this type, we
will need information that tells
us what values of X tend
to occur together with what
values of Y. And this
information is captured in
the so-called joint PMF.
So the joint PMF is nothing but
a piece of notation for an
object that's familiar.
This is the probability that
when we carry out the
experiment we happen to see
random variable X take on a
value, little x.
And simultaneously see that
random variable Y takes on a
value, little y.
This quantity we indicate
it with this notation.
The letter little p
stands for a PMF.
The subscripts tell us which
random variables
we're talking about.
And finally, this is a function
of two arguments.
Depending on what pair (x,y)
we're interested in, we're
going to get a different
numerical value for this
probability.
As an example of a joint PMF
in which the two random
variables take values in a
finite set, we might be given
a table of this form.
Using this table, we can answer
questions such as the
following--
what is the probability that the
random variables X and Y
simultaneously take the values,
let us say, 1 and 3?
Then we look up in this table,
and we identify that it's this
probability, X takes the
value of 1, and Y takes
the value of 3.
And according to this table,
the answer would be 2/20.
Now, something to notice
about joint PMFs.
When you add over all possible
pairs, x and y, this exhausts
all the possibilities.
And therefore, these
probabilities should add to 1.
In terms of this table, all of
the entries that we have here
should add to 1.
Now, once we have in our hands
the joint PMF, we can use it
to find the individual PMFs of
the random variables X and Y.
And these individual PMFs are
called the marginal PMFs.
How do we find them?
Well, the joint PMF tells us
everything there is to be
known about the two random
variables, so it should
contain enough information
for us to
answer any kind of question.
So for example, if we wish to
find the probability that the
random variable X takes the
value of 4, we look at all
possible outcomes in which X
is equal to 4, and add the
probabilities of
these outcomes.
So in this case, it would
be 1/20 plus 2/20.
So what we're doing is that if
we're interested in a specific
value of X, the probability
that X takes on a specific
value, we consider all possible
pairs associated with
that fixed x.
That is, we're considering one
column of the PMF, and we're
adding the corresponding
probabilities.
So to find this entry here,
let's say px(3), what we need
is to add these terms
on that column.
Similarly, we can find the PMF
of the random variable Y.
So for example, the probability
that the random
variable Y takes on a value of,
let's say, 2, can be found
as follows.
You look at the probabilities
of all pairs associated with
this specific y, and you
add over the x's.
So we fix Y to have a value of
2, and we add over all pairs
in this row.
So in this example, it would be
1/20 plus 3/20, plus 1/20.
Finally, notice that we are able
to answer the question
that got us motivated
in the first place.
To find the probability that the
two random variables take
equal values, we look at all the
outcomes for which the two
random variables indeed take
the same numerical values.
And we see that it is this event
in this diagram, and the
probability of that event
is going to be 2/20.
So in general, once we have
available the joint PMF of two
random variables, we will be
able to answer any questions
regarding probabilities of
events that have to do with
these two random variables.
How about more than two
random variables?
It's just a matter
of notation.
For example, we can define the
joint PMF of three random
variables, and you can use the
same idea for the joint PMF,
let's say, of five, or 10,
or n random variables.
Let's just look at the
notation for three.
There is a well-defined
probability that when we carry
out the experiment X, Y and Z
as random variables take on
certain specific values.
So we look at the probability of
that particular triple, and
we indicate that probability
with this notation.
Once more, the sub-scripts tell
us which random variables
we're talking about.
And the PMF, of course, is going
to be a function of this
triple, little x, little y,
little z, because each triple
in general should have a
different probability.
Of course, probabilities
must always add to 1.
So when we consider all triples
and we add their
corresponding probabilities,
we should get 1.
And finally, once we have the
joint PMF, we can again
recover the marginal PMF.
For example, to find the
probability that the random
variable takes on a specific
value, little x, we consider
all possible triples in which
the random variable indeed
takes that value, little x.
And then we sum over all the
possible y's and z's that
could go together with
this particular x.
In the same spirit, to find the
probability that these two
random variables take on two
specific values, we consider
all the possible z's that could
go together with this
(x,y) pair.
So this way we're ranging over
all outcomes in which X and Y
take on these specific values.
But Z is free to take any value,
and so we consider all
those possible values of Z
and sum the corresponding
probabilities.
Finally, we can talk
about functions of
multiple random variables.
Suppose that we have two random
variables, x and y, and
that we define a function
of them.
So this function is, of course,
a random variable.
And we can find the PMF of this
random variable if we
know the joint PMF of X and Y.
So the PMF, which is the
probability that the random
variable takes on a specific
numerical value, that's the
probability that the function of
X and Y takes on a specific
numerical value.
And we can find this probability
by adding the
probabilities of all
(x,y) pairs.
Which (x,y) pairs?
Those (x,y) pairs for which the
value of Z would be equal
to this particular number,
little z, that we care about.
So we collect essentially all
possible outcomes that make
this event to happen, and we add
the probabilities of all
those outcomes.
Finally, similarly to the case
where we have a single random
variable and function of it, we
now can talk about expected
values of functions of two
random variables, and there is
an expected value rule that
parallels the expected value
rule that we had developed
for the case of a
function of this form.
The form that the expected value
rule takes is similar,
and it's quite natural.
The interpretation
is as follows.
With this probability,
a specific
(x,y) pair will occur.
And when that occurs, the value
of our random variable
is a certain number.
And the combination of these
two terms gives us a
contribution to the
expected value.
Now, we consider all possible
(x,y) pairs that may occur,
and we sum over all
these (x,y) pairs.